how capable are ukraine's armed forces
against russia's today
let's take a look
ukraine has about 200 000 military
personnel across its forces that's large
but tiny when compared to russia which
has around 900 000 regular military
personnel
ukraine though has around 900 000 in
reserve now those are people who have
been trained to a military standard in
the last five years
again though they are dwarfed by russia
which has around two million reserves
[Music]
on the equipment front the russians are
also in a much better position the
russians are in a position to be able to
mount a major military action in ukraine
any day now they have more than six
times the number of tanks as ukraine
with 13
367 to ukraine's 2119
they have also almost seven times the
number of armored vehicles as the
ukrainians with
19783 versus ukraine's
2870 and they have more than three times
the amount of artillery those are large
weapons like howitzers cannons mortars
many of them operated by crews
in the air again it is a similar story
russia has more than 10 times the number
of helicopters and fast jets
the ukrainians do have over 400
surface-to-air missile launchers that
could target aircraft although this is
still only a tenth of the number
possessed by russia
and russia has an anti-aircraft missile
system that many analysts say is the
best in the world the s-400 nato call it
the growler it uses long-range missiles
to destroy airborne targets with a 400
kilometer radius and it gives russia a
defense system against foreign aircraft
[Music]
russia's military dominance over ukraine
is greatest at sea in 2014 when russia
invaded crimea it captured most of the
ukrainian fleet
and so russia now has 74 warships and 51
submarines
and it has experience using them in
conflict russian warships have launched
cruise missiles from the caspian sea
against islamic state targets in syria
hybrid warfare is something that russia
has mastered in recent years and would
almost certainly be a factor in any
conflict with ukraine so cyber attacks
for example
targeting ukraine's national
infrastructure
so ukraine versus russia is something of
an uneven comparison but the numbers do
become more favorable though when you
factor in nato we don't know what will
happen but what we do know is that
russia has amassed the biggest
force we have seen in europe for decades
nato has said that it will not send in
ground troops to defend ukraine because
ukraine is not a member of nato instead
they are giving assistance at arm's
length but there are around three and a
half million military personnel if you
add up all of the nato member states
together and so nato against russia in
military terms
is a far more even contest